power that's why you clicked on this
video the answer to why you should watch
chainsaw man is power but other than
this anime's best girl like me Makino
fans and the subject of next year's most
popular Comic Con cosplay there are a
ton of reasons to check out the biggest
Premiere this season and there are some
on this list especially the last one
that will want to make you go and watch
it right now but watch this video first
for the last couple of weeks everyone's
been sharing still frames from the
trailer and has been foaming from the
mouth out of pure anticipation for this
and now it's finally here so what
exactly is all this
[Applause]
well chainsaw man is adapted from a
manga by tatsuki Fujimoto also known for
some more Niche but nonetheless
fantastic stories like fire punch look
back and goodbye 80. and in theory it's
your typical Shonen anime but really
only in theory here's the premise of the
story denji is a teenage boy rendered
homeless after inheriting his father's
crushing Yakuza deaths and he lives in a
world that's populated by what the show
calls Devils creatures created from
Human fears whose strength and power
depends on well pretty much how much
people piss their pants because of these
fears and so after being I mean a put to
rest by one of these Devils denji's life
is ultimately saved by the mandatory
cute mascot Pota a little chainsaw doggo
so uh how does that work man you ask
well puchita becomes denji's heart thus
granting him the power to fuse with the
chainsaw devil in sight and as a result
becoming chainsaw man by far and this is
just my personal opinion which is
correct the most badass looking anime
protagonist I have ever seen so by
pulling the chords that now emerges from
his chest then he can Now activate his
chainsaw man transformation chainsaws
come out of his arms chainsaws come out
of his legs a chainsaw comes out of his
freaking face a bit of a sick [ __ ] for
really enjoying this ain't I but uh hey
sorry you surrogate and so with this
newfound power denji becomes a public
safety devil Hunter what is that you ask
well it basically means that he's
joining a team of good people that keep
the world safe from the threat of these
Devils now at first glance you might say
that this is a premise that's not too
far distant from the likes of
bleacho or juice kaisen were
irresponsible adults who are too lazy or
incompetent to actually take care of
things themselves find unwitting kids
gaining Supernatural powers that they
use to protect Humanity from Evil
entities but whereas these shows still
fit the basic mold of their Shonen Jump
peers even while having darker edges
than even more mainstream shows like
Naruto or one piece chainsaw man
assuredly does not because in reality
chainsaw man is anything but a typical
Shonen let me tell you what the biggest
selling point of Chainsaw man as a story
is the super unique tone and feel that
it has one example coming right up the
chainsaws in questions for instance are
not The Lumberjack variety to cut down
trees but have a more of a Texas
massacre Vibe going for them in case I'm
not bringing this across here that's
code four totally [ __ ] up this series
is violence this series is bloody this
series is Gory it's dark and twisted and
messed up and I love it now if that sort
of thing appeals to you then chainsaw
man might just be the show for you
fujimoto's artwork has a way of bringing
the intense action of the series
completely to life even on a static
black and white image I mean really just
look at some of his panels you can
basically see the violent intensity of
sauce ripping through flesh and boat and
now you don't have to squeeze your eyes
to imagine but can actually sit on your
couch eat your popcorn and watch those
epic bloody sequences and panels come to
life in color and motion where you can
listen to the Roar of the chainsaws and
the gushing Fountains of blood you sick
sick [ __ ] is this the most violent manga
ever of course not berserk exists but if
you're into the dark the gritty and the
gruesome then this is something new for
your repertoire it's certainly not the
only show with a dark and violent
aesthetic but to read something like
chance a man in the pages of Shonen Jump
alongside one piece and my hero Academia
can come as quite a shock to some people
and now of course with Wonder products
Studio mapa at the helm of this
adaptation fans have plenty to be
excited about the studio really has
already proved itself capable of some
great action animation with the final
season of Attack on Titan and the
brilliantly rendered Jiu Jitsu kaisen
series and in addition to the action
mapa has experience in more tender
emotional storytelling being the studio
that brought us for example Yuri on ice
and uh speaking of that tender and
emotional storytelling I've tricked you
all the biggest selling point of this
manga isn't the gritty violence at all
because one of the most powerful assets
that chainsaw man really has is its
World building I mean it starts with
that simple enough premise but what
seems standard and procedural at first
becomes a web of political Intrigue
conflicting character motivations and
deepening Mysteries rather uh heard that
one before once again it starts off
similar to a show such as bleach or yoyo
Hakusho in the former Kurosaki Ichigo
finds Newfound Powers as a Shinigami and
now uses them to dispatch of Hollows in
yoaksho yasuke urameshi finds himself as
a spirit detective hunting Rogue demons
however both of these shows quickly
abandoned their early premises in favor
of a more battle heavy format let's say
bleach trades it for the tried and true
formula of fighting a new set of cool
guys each new arc and yoak show features
perhaps the greatest tournament Arc of
all time and while both of these series
are legendary among Shonen anime for a
very good reason chainsaw man opts for a
completely different and quite
refreshing new approach to this doesn't
skimp on the violence obviously this is
the most blood you're going to see this
season promised however beneath the tide
of bombastic action is an undercurrent
of genuine philosophical exploration on
a level you don't see in that many
series honestly chainsaw man takes place
in a world of devils and while these
Devils fill a definite monster of the
weak role there are also so much more
than that these monsters are fear
manifested their strength correlates to
how much cumulative fear the human
population has of the concept which they
represent therefore if you want a good
example of this things like a shark
devil or the spider devil are fairly
strong creatures cause many people are
scared of these things and in this way
the general premise is quite similar to
jutsukaisen where curses are born of
fear and negative energies of humans
however and this is where things get
interesting chainsaw man also tends to
imbue their Devils with a greater level
of social commentary than Jutsu kaisen's
curse Spirits now if you've watched this
channel before this is not a dick at due
to kaisen I still love you jogo you're
the best personified volcano around but
really sharks and spiders are just the
tip of the iceberg chainsaw man's Devils
explore much deeper existential fears
and that's where things get interesting
and really crazy easy it's no mistake
that a central antagonist of Chainsaw
man is the gun devil an unspeakable
monster born out of Humanity's
Collective fear of gun violence it's no
surprise that this Series has resonated
strongly with an American audience so
far I mean after all it's a country
plagued by gun violence at rates higher
than any other developed Nation the gun
devil and the looming threat represents
is all too real in our world as well
chainsaw man uses its devil premise not
only to set up awesome gruesome action
but to make real political and
philosophical statements and Fujimoto
really takes his characters to hell and
back literally to explore the depth of
human fear now this is obviously a no
spoiler Zone but just you wait for the
darkness devil to be animated let's just
say I'm looking forward to seeing one of
the wildest panels in all of manga in
motion and I know that sounds a little
bit over the top but if you know you
know when chainsaw man tackles fears
fundamental to The Human Experience
things get absolutely Bonkers yeah I
mean lots of the devil's abilities come
from conventional Weaponry by chainsaws
but some devils have some insane powers
on display but wait a minute this is
still like the beginning of the story
like you see how much longer is left in
this video like this isn't the story
what's crazy about chainsaw man is what
comes next because despite all the Epic
action and the crazy Powers this is
nothing compared to chainsaw man's
biggest selling points because this is
where the story gets very juicy after
mentioning power about 269 times already
I know you didn't come here for me to
not talk about chainsaw man's characters
they Rock every single one every cast
member of Chainsaw man is my best friend
and he's my best friend Aki is my best
friend power is my best friend makima is
my actual mom pachita is not denji's
heart Vegeta is my heart to put it into
words the characters into chainsaw man
are fully realized each is lovable but
they're also flaws corrupt and
corruptable Fujimoto clearly went to the
Shrek School of character design because
much like an ogre or an onion these
characters have layers let's start with
denji he's your typical teenage boy a
homeless dead slave to Mobsters okay so
this show has some definite commentary
on capitalism by the way wealth
inequality Etc maybe he's not your
typical teenage boy but in a lot of ways
he's a more realistic teenage boy than a
lot of other Shonen protagonists if you
know what I mean I mean Luffy wants to
be the pirate king Naruto wants to be
Hokage midoriya wants to be a great
superhero blah blah blah denji wants to
get a girlfriend and more importantly to
him he wants to touch boobs relatable
who doesn't want to touch boobs so uh
which one really sounds more like the
teenage boys in your life then she's a
kid who's never had a normal life he's
never had steady meals gone to school
had friends held a real job or really
anything as a result his personality is
Brash rude and immature but and this is
important he's not without a level of
empathy and a willingness to play the
hero and save lives as much as chainsaw
man is about being a hero it's also
about trying to find a purpose and a
role to play in one's life it's about
holding down a job there's a good reason
that his transformation into chainsaw
man maintains a button-down shirt and a
tie as you didn't notice he's not
wearing a superhero escape this form
even with a chainsaw exploding from his
face is his workplace attire denji wants
a normal life and violently slaying
Devils is the only way to achieve that
goal for him makima another fan favorite
character because let's face it they're
all fan favorite characters is the one
who coerces denji into becoming a public
safety devil Hunter it's really either
work for her and be treated as a human
or hunted as a devil denji for one is
more than happy to become a contributed
member of society and get three Square
meals a day and it doesn't hurt either
that she tempts in with the promise of a
potential relationship and he jumps at
the chance to achieve his dream of
dreams as a leader of the devil Hunters
makima is as powerful as she's
mysterious and has always had a way of
getting what she wants and then there's
Aki the edgy character of our main Trio
because every series needs a Sasuke
however Migo mifushiguro of jutsakaisen
is a more at comparison here given that
Aki II summons Beast to do some of the
fighting for him Aki has made contracts
with Devils who will lend their powers
in exchange for a price for instance he
can summon the fox devil for the low low
price of letting the devil consume a
part of his body truly a steal Aki has a
character in contrast is fully motivated
by Revenge he has a personal stake in
the fight against the gun devil here you
see his entire family was killed by this
monster the last time it appeared as a
result he takes his job as a devil
Hunter Deadly series and can't stand
other characters like denji who don't
many characters human and devil alike
are morally great Aki and other devil
Hunters as well as governments and other
organizations regularly make contracts
with devils and devils are not a united
front of evil just like humans they're
mostly looking out for their own
self-interest and if that means working
alongside humans then so be it of course
there are also plenty of human
characters who demonstrate that in many
ways humans can just be as vile as
Devils big surprise oh yeah and before I
forget there's uh one Central character
I still haven't talked about much power
power is a blood fiend a fiend being a
devil that's possessed a human corpse
power is childish greedy a compulsive
liar rude unkempt and unsanitary she's
also taken first and third place in the
two chainsaw man popularity polls and
for a very good reason as the blood
devil she can manipulate her own and
others blood shaping it into various
Weaponry often a scythe Now power is the
only character who can match denji's
extreme immaturity much to the dismay of
the orderly Aki but then other than
comic relief what's her actual appeal
though well be sure to watch the anime
for all the spoilery content that
depends on her character but for now
suffice to say that she loves her cat
very much and loving a cat is easily
enough Redemption for any other negative
personality traits and so to bring it
all back chainsaw man has the typical
Shonen structure but it's subversive on
every single level it has extreme
violence and Gore but still maintains a
real emotional resonance it's absurd and
comical but explores deep philosophical
topics with expert Precision oh and uh
all the characters are really really hot
which makes chainsaw man the show so you
have to watch this season thank you very
much for watching